so i may not beat you as an entrepreneur  but i may go hand in hand on the  happiness because i'm happy as far as  that is the best that's the best  that makes me emotional in the best way  that is the purpose of every way i'm  trying to communicate which is unless  you were completely upset for me  the happiness part is the only part  i was happy as [ __ ] in this store down  there in 2001 where nobody in the world  knew who the [ __ ] i was i was as happy  21 years ago in this building and it  wasn't even this building this was built  later it was a little building down  there facing that street right down  there  21 years ago as i am this exact second  not a dollar not a fan not a nothing  nothing that has happened to me publicly  in the last 20 years has added a single  ounce of happiness  the process is my happiness